[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
here we are it's Monday December 5th and
we've got to talk about what the
Constitution is
and why dick pics are against Twitter's
terms of service
some dick pics how some
just the ones without consent those
types of dick pics
are against Twitter this is all [ __ ]
ridiculous we have so much news to get
to today and I can't even believe that I
have to start off with
the fact that the former president in
the United States actually believes that
he can suspend the Constitution and
install himself as president because
Twitter deleted Hunter Biden's big old
dick pics
it is I I don't even
we're in such a stupid [ __ ] timeline
this is so [ __ ] dumb from start to
finish
this this Twitter files story of course
my co-host Gabe Sanchez cannot wait to
get on air
um to talk about this
because it's so [ __ ] dumb
it's so [ __ ] dumb there's there's so
much to unpack
of this stupid story and it's all
because it's all because they're doing
what what they're accusing the Democrats
doing the cabal it's really [ __ ] dumb
it's a billionaire
it's one of the the richest he was I
don't know if he is anymore the richest
person in the world
the epitome of elite
is is using information
to distort politics with misinformation
and [ __ ] lies
and and using using what
what would be considered
you know 15 years ago 10 years ago a
journalist Matt taibi is not is not a
credible journalist it is clear on that
it's clear that in in this story alone
destroys destroys any credibility that
Matt taibi had at all
you are you are doing
exactly what you're accusing other folks
of doing
while not providing proof
of the accusation other than other than
Twitter [ __ ] deleted dick pics
of Hunter Biden
apparently they were dick pics of Hunter
Biden that's what whoever was posing
them claimed now I don't know if they
were posting him because they wanted
this big old hog
they this is weird [ __ ] that manga is
just obsessed not with the laptop
but with pictures of Hunter Biden's dick
absolutely obsessed with it and they
believe this is evidence of some kind of
Chinese collusion with Joe Biden or some
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yes Hunter Biden's a weirdo he's taking
pictures of his dick and storing him on
a laptop
okay so what's the point
what's the point what's the [ __ ]
public interest
a posting dick pics on Twitter
what's the public interest what's the
journalistic value here
did he send them to somebody oh you
stole them off the laptop you stole them
and you posted them without consent
seems seems as if the story is about the
weirdos stealing [ __ ] dick pics off
people's devices and posting them on the
Internet seems like that is the story
here not that Hunter Biden
somehow with this big huge [ __ ]
involved Joe Biden some kind of
conspiracy with China some stupid ass
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] they
believe anymore it's it's I can't even
tell you how [ __ ] weird this weekend
is
that Republicans are standing around
going he said what about the
Constitution
Donald Trump wants to suspend the cons
of course he wants to suspend the
Constitution what how in the [ __ ] don't
you know this
on January 6 he wanted to subvert the
Constitution what did you think was the
[ __ ] was gonna happen on January 6th if
Mike Pence did what Donald Trump told
him to do what did you think it was
going to do
hold the Constitution up on height no he
was going to tear it up and shred it in
little bitty [ __ ] pieces wipe his ass
with it put some ketchup on it maybe eat
it maybe throw it against the wall who
the [ __ ] knows there wouldn't have been
a constitution if he would have got what
he wanted on January 6 you dumb
[ __ ] of course he doesn't like
the Constitution it stands in his way to
be a dictator
it stands in their way Republicans the
Maga America First Nazi party from
taking our rights away
what don't you understand what don't you
get why can why can't the American
people collectively pluck their head out
of their ass and realize that the
Republican party has become a party of
Nazis
authoritarian Nazis they want white rule
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] you
can what you can't do who you can be
Jesus Christ they're shooting up [ __ ]
power grids and more County North
Carolina to make sure lgbtq people can't
meet at a meeting or some [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] snowflakes and they're Nazis
it's not complicated it really isn't and
the media is making it really [ __ ]
stupid and complicated here Elon Musk
bought Twitter
Elon Musk has has to have some he he
obviously with Matt taibi who lived in
[ __ ] Moscow for years who definitely
Putin has dirt on him just like Glenn
Greenwald
Putin definitely has dirt on Matt Tybee
more than likely has dirt on Elon Musk
what do you think this is about how do
you think he's a [ __ ] Saudi money to
buy Twitter this isn't complicated you
stupid son of a [ __ ] and mug up
[ __ ]
everything you're accusing everything
all of it the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] in
caboodle
everything you're accusing your
political enemy of it's all projection
and if it's not personal projection it's
Collective projection
you you carry on about the [ __ ]
Elites you carry on about it how the
elites are taken over and they're trying
to control your mind with the media and
you [ __ ] believe some stupid
[ __ ] Twitter thread when it shows you
the evidence Matt taibi even says in the
thread that the Biden Campaign which is
not the government
a political campaign is not the
government but he does cite the Trump
White House which is the [ __ ]
government had access to Twitter
you stupid [ __ ]
and again I go back to you and trying to
explain it to you last week what the
[ __ ] difference between hate speech
and free speeches
but this applies here too this is
private [ __ ] property you dumb
bastards
Twitter has a terms of service if you
break their terms of service they can
take your [ __ ] down
foreign
they do not have to allow you to have an
account on Twitter that's not a [ __ ]
thing
it's not a law it's not in the
Constitution that you guys want to
destroy by the way and you're cheering
cheering the authoritarian Vigor who
wants to suspend the Constitution
because Twitter took down dick pics you
people are the dumbest [ __ ] on
the planet
and I don't know that we will fix that I
don't think we're going to I don't think
we're going to do I seem pissed off this
morning I'm more pissed off that these
[ __ ] idiots don't see don't see
what's happening and really they don't
want to see it
every single Republican elected official
everywhere who has who has been an
election and either lost or won should
be standing up and saying it's
he is not fit to he is not fit to even
[ __ ] say
the word president let alone be the
[ __ ] president and let alone be our
[ __ ] nominee the RNC should be this
morning this morning writing out memos
that they will not they will not
endorse him on any [ __ ] ballot states
should be passing state laws right now
that will not allow that seditious
[ __ ] to be on a ballot
that's what we should be doing right now
he wants to suspend the Constitution
which again he he finally says the quiet
part out loud right like we [ __ ] knew
this from January 6th we knew this we
knew what he was doing that day we
[ __ ] understood that [ __ ]
it's not it's not hard to [ __ ] get
when he was telling his people go down
there [ __ ] take over the [ __ ]
government
and if Mike Pence won't take over the
government well then he's our enemy and
then they went down there and they were
chanting hang Mike Pence so much so that
Mike Pence had to hide in a [ __ ]
basement with his family and his staff
only to wait for to have the [ __ ]
moglodytes cleared out of the capital so
they could do what they were supposed to
do which is a [ __ ] ceremony not even
a real vote for that matter it's just
it's just for show it's like at the
Oscars when they open the envelope and
say the words into the microphone it
already been done it already been voted
on it was a thing
there was no changing it
really stupid [ __ ]
but all of a sudden the media is like ow
this guy wants to suspend the
Constitution
and this is what this is why we have
these problems
this is why we have these problems
honestly uh there's a clip and I'm going
to show you this clip uh of George
Stephanopoulos questioning I forget the
representative's name he's a [ __ ]
Republican he absolutely refuses to say
that he will not vote for anyone who
wants to suspend the Constitution
because they're a [ __ ]
and they're a [ __ ] loser and they
can't stand losing that is not a reason
to suspend the Constitution at all not
even [ __ ] close
but in this clip George Stephanopoulos
should have looked at this [ __ ]
and said hey if you don't answer my
question
you will not be back on our show if you
can't answer this simple [ __ ]
question you can't handle doing media
so answer the question or we will never
invite you back
you are a seditious piece of garbage
it's enough of this stuff it's enough of
trying to placate to the Nazis to to
manage the Nazis feelings [ __ ] you kiss
my [ __ ] ass
like over the weekend where we watch the
[ __ ] Patriot front and proud boys
those [ __ ] goddamn bigot ass
[ __ ]
stop it stopping a story time show
because they get uncomfortable with
other people dressing and dancing in a
certain way
that's a you problem [ __ ]
that's a you problem you goddamn
snowflakes
that is a [ __ ] you problem
shooting up power grids in North
Carolina because they're they are afraid
they're afraid of someone else thinking
the way they don't think this all sounds
familiar doesn't it this is all the [ __ ]
they accuse us of it's all projection
every [ __ ] bit of it is collective
projection and there's no better example
of it than this [ __ ] weekend
with the Twitter files Twitter files
we're gonna we're gonna release all the
information on the hunter Biden laptop
not a goddamn thing about the laptop not
a thing not a [ __ ] thing about the
laptop not one
the only the only the only story I saw
was that Elon Musk used his Elite power
to spread misinformation and to bury a
story
which the story really truly is that the
Republicans want the information on the
on the laptop to [ __ ] interfere in a
2024 election that's what they want
be damned the truth [ __ ] the truth don't
give a [ __ ] about the truth
and if they have to suspend the
Constitution like Grandpa Poopypants
wants them to well by God they just
might do it because there ain't one of
them [ __ ] standing out there today
saying [ __ ] him [ __ ] him he's not a
republican there should be an asterisk
next to his goddamn presidency and his
name he's not an American he's not a
patriot [ __ ] charge him charge him
now with this document's case and
January 6 with the fake elector scheme
which I believe Jack Smith is in the
process of doing I'm very confident
we've got an election tomorrow
now in Georgia it is that that that is
top of mind for our democracy
now it it seems to be that
Georgians aren't that excited about
having Herschel Walker who can't hardly
collect up enough brain cells to talk
about anything but werewolves and
[ __ ] vampires
what a closing argument
whoosh
and shame shame on anyone who in Georgia
who goes and casts a ballot for Herschel
Walker you dumb [ __ ] you dumb
[ __ ] just stay at home you
ain't gotta vote for Warnock if you
don't want to but to go vote for
Herschel walk you are piles of garbage
piles of [ __ ] garbage
and I believe that's the big story that
we have here
and I've been talking about it for a
long time
that we have a small percentage it's a
small percentage you know in the teens
but it's a large group of people that
are absolutely
deluded
absolutely mind [ __ ]
and it's only because they want to be
this is Will for ignorance okay
to watch to watch what happened on
Twitter with Elon Musk and Matt taibi
and this Hunter Biden story
and you don't understand that every
single person that's like oh my God it's
gonna crack open the entire world no it
was Dick Pics you [ __ ] morons and of
course the presidential campaign for Joe
Biden had a liaison at Twitter that they
communicated with just like the Trump
campaign and the Trump White House which
Matt Tybee alludes to the government
the other thing too that absolutely
transmit taibi's credibility and I know
this sounds trivial but he [ __ ] doxes
Jack dorsey's email
listen if you're a journalist listen to
me out there if you're a real [ __ ]
journalist you're not going to Docs
Jack dorsey's email on a Twitter thread
that you have that you have made sure
that you have vetted Jesus Christ Elon
Musk was late and they were they were
still trying to fact check
they didn't even have the [ __ ] story
together when they went to release it
because it's not a story it's not
the other thing about the whole [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] is that Matt taibi
on his [ __ ] blog said that he he
had conditions from Elon well what he
couldn't could not do so he couldn't
actually do what you would call
journalism
he had to release it the way that Elon
wanted and really honestly I I have no
idea what's going to happen uh as far as
uh libel here
and defamation but I would say hunter
Biden has a really good [ __ ] case
against Elon Musk Matt taibi and Twitter
at this point
and so does the Biden campaign
now I doubt that the campaign's gonna
take action but if if I were honor Biden
I'd [ __ ] see the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you goddamn right
I tried to take 44 billion dollars Barry
Twitter once and for good [ __ ] him
because the [ __ ] they put out
at best at best was [ __ ] revenge porn
and really it is kind of funny that a
bunch of [ __ ] CIS white dudes are are
who are obsessed with genitalia and
other people's [ __ ] sexuality and
what their pronouns are and [ __ ] are
jerking off to Hunter Biden's big old
ass [ __ ] on [ __ ] Twitter because
that's what they were doing
foreign
that's what they were doing what do you
want from me I I don't get to decide
what the story is I just have to talk
about it
and we are in a situation in our country
where we're talking about one of the
most famous hip-hop artists of all time
saying he loves Hitler
which is causing a sea wave of people to
just outright say they're Nazis
we have
we have a billionaire Elite the richest
man in the world
releasing a [ __ ] story about the
degenerate son of a president
and the story is that someone stole his
dick pics and posted them on this social
media platform that he now owns and
because it broke their terms of service
they deleted them that's the [ __ ]
that's literally what we're dealing with
and it's supposed to be the world's
groundbreaking story and Joe Biden's
gonna have to resign and Donald Trump
should be reinstalled as the president
United States I'm not [ __ ] you
that's what they're saying
foreign
and it's all projection the entire
[ __ ] whole that whole thing is
projection
because if Matt Ty ebi actually did his
[ __ ] job
and Elon Musk allowed him to have access
to everything I would almost bet almost
bet a lot of [ __ ] money that the
Trump White House and the Trump campaign
was doing exactly exactly what manga is
accusing the Biden campaign of doing
which is interfering in an election with
the media
foreign
bet
that that's what was happening
they act like this Hunter Biden laptop
story being buried is such a big [ __ ]
deal
oh really
so all the sexual assaults that Trump
had that they were trying to bury that
that Stormy Daniels story
the check the hush money payment that
Michael Cohen went to prison for that
wasn't cut get me a [ __ ] break this
is all projection and all [ __ ] all
of it there is no Hunter buyings laptop
no one gives a [ __ ] about Hunter Biden's
laptop only Maga cares about seeing
Hunter Biden's huge [ __ ] that's it
that's it
do you CA do you as a pro-democracy
person who cares about our [ __ ]
country who cares about our nation who
really gives a [ __ ] about our [ __ ]
Constitution do you really do you really
in your heart of hearts think that
pictures of what could be Hunter Biden's
[ __ ] is important to the public
knowledge
really
we ain't got better [ __ ] to deal with
than this nonsense
and I know it's all distraction
I know it's all distraction
but folks this is their narrative
this is their narrative
that they want to suspend the
Constitution because Twitter wouldn't
allow people to post dick pics of Hunter
Biden
and also
we focus on genitalia
in Columbus Ohio and North Carolina
they're [ __ ] they're absolutely [ __ ]
they're absolutely obsessed with penis
the Republican party is obsessed with
penis
and it's it's it's amazing
it's amazing and you know it's not
surprising it's not surprising a bunch
of [ __ ] Nazis you want to dress up
you want to have cosplay who want to
dance to the YMCA
you know I'm not I
want to look at [ __ ] pictures of
penis that's so be it maybe you want to
watch porn [ __ ] I'm all for it hell I I
really as long as it's consenting porn I
don't give a [ __ ]
what you're watching at your [ __ ]
business to be quite honest with you
whatever gets your rocks off I don't
give a [ __ ]
but but for this for this [ __ ]
movement this Nazi fascist movement
who is absolutely [ __ ] and obsessed
with Cox
dick pics
they're obsessed with other people's
genitalia what the what what [ __ ] they
got in their pants
are called The Proud boys
mind you dancing to the YMCA to protest
at LGBT leave them the [ __ ] alone
Tony how did you make the Elon Twitter
story and Donald Trump wanting to spend
the Constitution part of The Proud boy
story it's all the same story it's all
the same story it's the same
[ __ ] Nazis it's the same ones
maybe we should start calling them the
[ __ ] Nazis the penis Nazis I don't know
come up with something
put it in the chat maybe we'll [ __ ]
make it Trend I don't know
they really do seem to be obsessed with
penis though I've been telling you a
long time Matt Walsh's obsession with
other people's genitalia is [ __ ]
weird it's weird [ __ ] I am never [ __ ]
gone into a public bathroom ever before
and was really obsessed and wondering
while I'm in the stall wondering what
the hell the genitalia in the next door
I get my [ __ ] I get the [ __ ] out it's
weird if you're doing anything else
especially if you're thinking about
other people's genitalia in a bathroom
especially a public bathroom you're the
[ __ ] weirdo you're the [ __ ]
predator
and when you're going and you're [ __ ]
shooting up uh Power Supplies so people
can't have [ __ ] power because you're
scared of your closeted but you you're
you people are closeted [ __ ]
and you're terrified of being closeted
you're terrified of those little
feelings deep down inside you that you
can't understand and you can't [ __ ] it
you you can't talk about because it
makes you feel uncomfortable because you
may be gays it's really [ __ ] dumb I'm
sick of it I'm [ __ ] sick of it it's
the same [ __ ] the same projection that
comes from the [ __ ] the former guy
down in Mar-A-Lago it's the same [ __ ]
projection from Elon Musk and Matt taibi
in every single [ __ ] Elon and
magazimp that was on Twitter jerking off
to to a nothing Burger
an absolute [ __ ] nothing Burger folks
the real story here is Kevin McCarthy
who is trying to become the Speaker of
the House you can't seem to muster up
218 votes in the house to become the
speaker says on a tweet
he tweets it hey you know that story
about the government
colluding with the media and Twitter and
it Millionaires and billionaire Elites
to try to make sure that Biden was
elected will us as Republicans as the
house as the government are going to
collude with Elon Musk and Twitter to
make sure we win the 2024 election
literally they're saying it out loud
foreign
they're saying it out loud they're
saying hey we're going to do this this
is what we're going to do
because they're accusing someone else of
doing something that's not even close to
what they're accusing them of but
they're going to do it
but Kevin McCarthy and the Republicans
if Kevin McCarthy's speaker which I
don't know if it will be or not but the
Republicans in the House of
Representatives are going to try to use
Elon Musk and Twitter and Hunter Biden's
laptop and those dick pics to interfere
in the 2024 election that's what they're
going to do because they're going to
want to bury stories about their
sedition their [ __ ] treason and they
and they're going to do whatever they
can to hang on to their power damn the
Constitution damn the people damn the
country they don't give a [ __ ] it's all
about their power every [ __ ] last bit
of it
everybody it's only Monday and we have a
waterfall a waterfall of story so stick
around don't go anywhere we're gonna get
to the shitless Roundup I'm gonna bring
my co-host and he's excited
about breaking down this Twitter file
story so everyone stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I'm fired up
it's Monday
yeah boy
attend the Constitution
[Music]
about when I was prepping for the show
this morning literally I'm gonna have to
explain to these [ __ ] again
what the Constitution is and why it is
so important
and how your little [ __ ] dick pics of
Hunter Biden have nothing to do with
what you're talking about dick pics and
the costume maybe that should have been
the title the titles trumps excuse me
Trump hates consequences and the
Constitution which is true he absolutely
hates consequences and the Constitution
and really honestly because a lot of
times and especially in the case of Jack
Smith the Constitution is going to
deliver those consequences uh to Donald
Trump I believe
um we watched as The Oath Keepers uh
mainly Stuart Rhodes the leader of the
keepers was charged and convicted by a
jury
of seditious conspiracy
and obstruction of official proceeding
and a few others but this sedition the
Sedition charge is very important here I
believe
as we wind up for the proud boys
um trial really is weird that um
we have domestic terrorist groups
that are
um
going all over the country trying to
intimidate people because of the way
they dress and who they are
to shut down their events
um it's really weird that that they're
on trial for seditious conspiracy their
head their leaders
and we're just like perfect course a
bunch of Nazis show up in Columbus Ohio
I have to tell you
I think I think this is very important
and I'm going to show some of these um
clips from Columbus in particular the
one where the proud boys
are protesting literally dancing to the
music YMCA which I'm not sure if they
know what that song's about
I'm not sure but it really is [ __ ]
it's weird [ __ ] it's a weird timeline
we're in this is definitely
definitely a time to be alive but you
also have
um Patriot front showed up you know the
the U-Haul U-Haul U-Haul
um gang you know the the Nazis that show
up in the back of uh you all trucks they
they all cover their faces
it seems kind of weird that they are
scared of covet all of a sudden I don't
know they wear masks now
you know surely it's not to cover their
identity surely it's because they don't
want to spread disease I'm sure that's
exactly what it is
you also have other white supremacy
groups show up and Nazis full-on Nazis
there was a lot of them
um giving the hell Hitler sign towards
counter protesters which there were
counter protesters there
voicing their opinion
it seems kind of funny though that the
event that was canceled in Columbus Ohio
and I forget the uh the organization
name but here's the thing is
um apparently they had been contacting
the police department and the police
department basically
in so many words told them to go [ __ ]
themselves that they would not provide
security for their event and apparently
they set up they had volunteers to set a
perimeter to try to make sure that
people were safe and they still felt so
unsafe and the reason why is because
these people are [ __ ] domestic
terrorists just like the same
[ __ ] lunatic with weapons who
went into Club Q to kill people because
of who they are
that's not Equity that's not Liberty
that's not a quality that's tyranny
that's Terror that's domestic terrorism
and it seems kind of weird that the
group who is on trial for seditious
conspiracy to overthrow our government
shows up in Columbus Ohio to intimidate
a certain marginalized Community to shut
down their event because they don't like
who they are you know like
to stifle their freedom of speech are
you listening out though CR out there
crypto Bros you Elon simps you [ __ ]
America First Nazis
talk about freedom of speech you talk
about freedom and liberty you can't let
these people be who they are because
you're scared of them you are such
[ __ ] pieces of garbage and your
snowflakes your snowflakes
you're terrified of what someone else
may or may not think
so much so that you're willing in North
Carolina to shoot up power grids to shut
down the power for 40 000 people which
I'm sure there's going to be several
criminal charges and I'm sure that the
sheriff is going to be involved in this
because it sounds like to me from some
of these reports that the sheriff
maybe one of The Proud boys himself I
don't know seems to hang out with a lot
of individuals that are implicated in
shutting tearing down the power grid and
committing domestic terrorism in Moore
County North Carolina
and this has everything to do this has
everything to do with what happened on
Twitter folks because the entire aim of
what happened on Twitter was to
absolutely
absolutely 100 percent undermined
undermine our vote and our decision even
two years ago we just had an election
they're still talking about the one
[ __ ] two years ago
so much so that the former guy
is wants to suspend Gabe Sanchez have
you ever heard anything like this before
in your life did you dream that this is
where we'd be at on a Monday morning and
December 5th we're talking about Hunter
Biden's dick pics and the Constitution
suspended no I I
I mean I'm hot this morning I'm pissed
off I'm not I'm not surprised yeah I
know you got a lot to say about this
Twitter files thing and I know I'm sure
you brought a lot of receipts with you
as Gabe Sanchez does he's he's always um
I mean it's not it's also I mean if any
I mean yes yes I do have the receipts
and I will call it out uh as it is which
is a complete
nothing Burger
um did you let me ask you because this
is important because I didn't go look at
them I did not have a desire to see uh
how how large apparently his [ __ ] is
very large
um I'm just I'm saying I didn't go I
don't have the evidence in front of my
eyes I did not go look at it what I'm
wondering is did you go check out
um how big
his no no yes I I can tell you well
here's the thing I've seen when they've
shared videos and photos before this
yeah because they're like oh there's
been another hack and it's like was
there or did you guys just hold on to
this jerk off and then release it he
just so this was a private collection
before they posted on Twitter is what
you're saying I mean here's the thing
every time you know you got Matt Gates
is like I've got the files on this thumb
drive and I went through with the fine
tune comb and I had a magnifying glass
and a lot
I mean really honestly this little this
looks like a bunch of white CIS males
who were closeted who love to look at
this laptop information and what is it's
a photo gallery of Hunter Biden's huge
[ __ ] because apparently he has a huge
[ __ ] so you've seen video where he's
slinging around some dick huh is that
what you're saying
yeah yeah I've seen video I've seen
photo I've seen James Wood you know very
upset clearly he's gonna Sue by the way
I know I know I did mention there's a
what was that that's coming out today
and I do throw a little shade towards
James Wood is that like Hunter Biden
[ __ ] shade because it's so big or yeah
yeah pretty much I I didn't have a lot
of money in there but yeah come on you
gotta the hilarity in this is that not
only are they [ __ ] they're wildly off
Mark about this information that they
were suppressing because it's against
Twitter's turns with service to post a
picture or even the suggestion of a
picture that is without consent of
someone like that's against the terms I
mean it look if anyone else out there
had photos of themselves from their
private computer that were stolen and
used without permission and posted on a
public forum like Twitter without
permission you would probably say that
shouldn't be on there I request a
takedown because I never gave it to
anyone I never said they could post it
on Twitter right and it was from I mean
it all comes back here well here's the
other thing too is is I think this is a
distinguishable difference because the
guy who had the laptop the guy at the
shop he was on Fox News saying he's
Vindicated which come on man you're not
Vindicated you stole the [ __ ] off his
laptop it's you stole it it's stolen but
even in Twitter's terms and service
there are certain photos you cannot pull
off other parts of the internet even
though it's public and post without that
person's consent you have to have
consent for certain types of [ __ ]
media that is a thing you have to have
it is not now unless it's a journalist
and there's something of public interest
and right then it becomes a different
situation because now it's not just a
[ __ ] dick pic you pulled off a
[ __ ] phone or a laptop somewhere and
you're claiming it's hunter bidens or
Joe Biden's you know I'm just thinking
about this I wonder if the president
United States it was inherent it and I
wonder if I wonder if that's why Donald
Trump is so [ __ ] jealous of Joe Biden
I know I'm getting off track here but I
wonder if Joe Biden's hog is just as big
as Hunters do you think he's got a dick
that hangs down to his knees if I don't
know if we have to assume that there are
certain things that are familial and
they run within the genetic makeup
family one could assume who knows maybe
it comes from Jill's side of the family
maybe it comes from Joe's side of the
family hey but if you think this is why
Junior's so pissed off because he is
[ __ ] really frustrated right he is
really frustrated about this Hunter
Biden story what's what's also funny is
if there was anyone who watched more
[ __ ] videos and photos of Hunter
Biden it they could not beat uh junior
junior is the one who throughout this
whole time he's like I'd spend 50 hours
in front of the intelligence Community
talking about this and he's so he's
priming then
he well no no in all regards to talking
about I think is what he was saying that
he was saying about Hunter Biden's
laptop of Hunter Biden's laptop which I
was like oh [ __ ] let me see if let me
find this video why does that what what
does he have to do with Hunter Biden's
laptop other than he's jealous of how
big Connor's [ __ ] is yeah this really
seems about honestly this is it feels
like to me this is where the story is at
that they're completely jealous because
I'll tell you something I don't give a
[ __ ] about Hunter Biden I could care
less about Hunter bite he's he's not in
office whatever benefiting right well
not only that the [ __ ] wasn't
out on the campaign Trail he wasn't out
campaigning he's still not grifting off
his dad he doesn't have some website
where he's selling T-shirts about his
[ __ ] dad or his or the [ __ ] Joe
Biden movement or the Joe Biden cult
none of that exists that's not a [ __ ]
thing and it's it's all because they are
inept they are they are ridiculous and
the hilarity of it here is it's all a
mass projection like Collective
projection on their part what I'm sorry
what I meant to say yeah was that he
spent 50 hours in front of Congress
about treason and all that he had to
testify and he's saying here I'll send
you the video right now he's saying that
he's pissed off that Hunter Biden didn't
have to do [ __ ]
so this is this is uh this is Junior
here right this is Junior on one of his
many Brands we're not quite in the uh
yeah we can wait wait for the [ __ ] list
to get into it well let's let's do this
you know what
let's just get into it because I know
you're gonna have a ton of videos a ton
of [ __ ] tweets to to pull up here for
this story and it is highly relevant and
the reason why it's relevant is because
the the only Republican running for
president the former president
um the the likely nominee of the
Republican party at this point because
they won't even condemn him for saying
he wants to circumvent the Constitution
and get rid of it they won't even
condemn him for having dinner with uh
right and Nazis not anti-semitic Nazis
right white supremacists yeah so let's
just do it let's just let's start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show okay so this is
we're in the shitless Roundup we round
up all the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends but hell with the Pomp and
Circumstances let's get right into it
this is John Jr being very jealous about
uh Hunter Biden it really is weird that
Don Jr is obsessed with Hunter Biden
it's almost like Gabe that he he has
this deep-seated thing about how his dad
was present and his dad doesn't love him
but the president United States loves
currently the president United States
Joe Biden loves his son unconditionally
yeah even though Hunter Biden is kind of
a [ __ ] up not kinda he is a [ __ ] up yeah
everybody is a [ __ ] up I mean you know
who lets their lamp top get a bunch of
dick pics stolen off of it I'm not
saying I mean you know how does a blind
computer technician
know see all the dick pics well you know
maybe I don't know it's weird okay let's
this is not as weird as this though
let's listen TV whether it's the the
intelligence committee uh and the people
in intelligence uh and reliables okay
the the [ __ ] the [ __ ] I can't
if he does this in every video right
like he's been doing the last in the
last few days he's
doing these finger puppets look at these
rabbits what the [ __ ] is going why why
does he I mean there is a thing where
you have quotes right and we do it here
every once in a while I'm like I have to
do quotes but like uh we we give an
audio version of this there's a video
version of it but like he's doing it
every other yeah word so that the
audience can understand I don't know
what he's doing is this on his Facebook
page where is Instagram where does he
this is he posts he posts these uh
sometimes he'll post them on Instagram
but most of the time you post them on uh
Facebook so if anyone wants to watch the
full
version it's on Facebook the full
version
yeah okay let's let's continue horses
say that this really happened
uh that went on for years
uh you know cost millions of dollars in
attorney's fees just so we understand
where we are like if that was me that
would be a major problem and yet
better this must be Russian
disinformation okay so if it was you it
would be an issue and the issue would be
hey there's these dick pics but you know
what else there is there's text message
that Donald Trump Jr released himself
showing the collusion
with Russian spies like literally you
dude you You released text messages of
you colluding with Russia in 2016. yeah
and the meeting with Paul manafort like
that's a thing that happened so yeah
there would be some public interest if
you were you know out there sending dick
pics to somebody but if you had them on
a laptop and some computer guy stole
them from you it would probably be a
story that hey Don Jr's dick pics got
stolen off a laptop look how small it is
like that would be the [ __ ] probably
the story but he seems jealous of the
difference between his picks and you
think he like Zooms in is that how he
gets well I think I think he does do a
lot of pinching and zooming on his own
photos I remember you know like we
mentioned right before this is maybe
he's jealous because of the size of
Hunter Biden's penis right right he's
very obsessed with you you mean you mean
it you mean in comparison in comparison
right and then you have to ask like oh
maybe it runs in the family and if that
were true and that is true probably who
knows uh based on what we know of Stormy
Daniels and her encounter her Brief
Encounter she said I think was the worst
60 seconds of her life with Donald Trump
Trump she said it's a small uh
mushroom-like appearance like it looked
like a like Toad from Mario so if that's
true then one has to assume that
probably Don Jr is in the same boat
right well a little short little frumpy
you know I'm I'm glad you brought up the
Stormy Daniels thing because I was
thinking about this over the weekend
because literally in the grand scheme of
things right what they're accusing what
Elon Musk Matt taibi the trumps and the
moglodytes yeah the America First Nazi
party is accusing and absolutely full
stop accusing Joe Biden the president
United States is bearing a story about
his son's [ __ ] right yeah like how other
what other and somehow it has to do
pictures of Hunter Biden's [ __ ] have to
do with Chinese payments or some [ __ ]
I'm not sure what the [ __ ] that how that
it works in you know then their little
diluted minds but somehow that's the
story that they're spinning and that it
was the media and Rich Elites that were
trying to suppress this story when
literally there is a story in the 2016
election that Michael Cohen went to
prison for
Michael Cohen went to prison paying a
hush payment to keep a story about how
little Donald Trump's [ __ ] was yeah
out of the media and out of the press
it's it's astonishing to me that that
that literally what they're accusing
Joe bidenov which is not a I don't think
Joe Biden had anything to do with this
other than and there were people
alleging they had pictures of his son's
[ __ ] on Twitter and he's like all right
that's you know it's breaking terms of
service it's his son's his family maybe
Donald Trump wouldn't let Juniors
um little dick pics
um he just let him out there [ __ ] it he
wouldn't he wouldn't try to challenge it
let's listen to what else Junior's
jealous about
I'm actually going to take this one
pretty personally because of Jesus I did
50 hours 50 hours of testimony before
the Senate intelligence committee the
house intelligence committee the house
Judiciary Committee
um about nonsense some of the most
powerful people in government uh you
know Adam Schiff the chairman of the
intelligence committee uh said publicly
numerous times that I had committed
treason
treason just so we understand treason is
a crime punishable by death you know for
me these days that's like Minor Details
it's like a Tuesday just another day so
he's comparing dick pics
to treason well yeah he doesn't think
it's fair he's like if I have to go in
and give testimony for the thing that my
dad did and I had knowledge of and I
always wanted to communicate with my
father on January 6 but he was ignoring
my text message so I had to text Mark
Meadows who's the chief of staff and
knew what was going on based on
testimony that we were given by people
uh uh during the January 6 Insurrection
hearings you would think oh yeah those
aren't the same one dude had dick pics
released without permission online and
they tried to get rid of them and then
the other guy was knowledge of what his
dad was trying to do and in full support
I mean that's really what the comparison
is so he's like oh no this isn't fair oh
no this is terrible well I wanted about
50 hours dude you you were there you
were helping Hunter Biden Hunter Biden
there's no evidence anywhere that
suggests that he has anything to do with
the White House that suggests he has
anything to do with decisions that are
being made in the government or in a
campaign yeah listen there is no
Democrats that I know of that [ __ ]
paid two thousand dollars to line up to
make to get an autographed picture with
Hunter Biden yeah it's not a thing
Hunter Biden isn't out actively going to
[ __ ] Church groups with Mike Flynn
with all these other [ __ ] seditious
bastards going around trying to overturn
the 2020 results there he's not doing
that [ __ ] he's not participating in
politics you are that's why you're being
scrutinized okay so here's the um here's
this is from our thumbnail the great
thumbnail that you made today
um but I want to show this um
statement because this this post
confirms what I've already known which
honestly a lot of people were saying oh
this is him admitting it but he already
admitted this [ __ ] yeah what do you
think January 6 was like I mean let's
let's be honest truth social is nothing
more than a goddamn diary for Trump he's
on there ranting and raving and today
people were so mean so I said I need to
terminate the Constitution because our
first amendment it's not your First
Amendment right you're violating the
terms of service of a company that you
agreed to use
you mean you're talking about the people
who posted the dick pics yeah yeah and
this is what this is in response to
right like he's be he's being upset that
DNC and other people reported these
tweets that were posting illegal like
because it is it'll it's illegal in the
sense like you were not given permission
and it was hacked or taken from a
computer from another place that wasn't
yours
and posted without permission and then
now all of these people like Trump and
James Woods and Don Jr and uh Elon Musk
and Matt Tybee and all these other
Republicans are super upset because
they're saying oh this is an invasion of
of uh or this is a a suppression of our
first amendment no this is not this is
not and please go read the Constitution
and please go read Twitter's terms of
service and then come back to me and say
oh yes this was in fact a violation of
your first amendment rights especially
when [ __ ] Joe Biden was not the
president
and there's a lot more in here I'm going
to break down as to the involvement of
which government was involved
but
we can go we can start here well here is
the statement so I don't read this
coherent [ __ ]
uncoherent sorry
um Co here let's put the air quotes on
it yeah
deranged mess of a post here and again
it's full of capitalized
um words and quotes well there's one
quote in here
but this is the deranged message that I
knew existed in this [ __ ]
chuckleheads mind on January 6. but here
it is
no with the revelation of massive and
widespread fraud and deception which
I don't even know
what that means because there's been no
relev revelation of massive widespread
fraud and deception I don't know there's
no evidence of that in working closely
with big tech companies I I assume he's
referring to Twitter there yeah the DNC
and the Democratic party which neither
none of those are the government uh do
you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out
or declare the rifle winner I'm just
trying to
read it as he's writing it or do you
have a new election question mark so
basically what he's saying there is hey
I want you to install me as the
President of the United States is
basically what he's saying in a question
so that you're not like oh look he's
wanting to just be the dictator like on
January 6 when he said at the ellipse
you know go to the Capitol take it over
take over the Constitution peacefully
though you know act like it's peacefully
because if I don't say that part then
I'll be in trouble like if I don't put a
question mark here or I'm absolutely
wanting
the election to be overturned two
elections ago okay he continues Grandpa
Poopypants continues here and this is
the one everyone's freaking out about
this is the statement that I knew he
believed already a massive fraud which
I'm not sure why the [ __ ] does he
capitalize [ __ ] like that
a massive fraud as if it's a title is
there a book out called massive fraud I
don't know I don't know Jesus Christ
okay so a massive fraud of this type and
magnitude allows for the termination of
all rules regulations and art and
articles even those found in the
Constitution literally what this guy is
saying is what he believed on January 6
because he didn't win because he's a
sore loser and he's a little [ __ ]
baby back punk ass [ __ ]
that he deserves to win no matter what
the rules say damn the Constitution damn
the country damn damn rule of law he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he is a little [ __ ]
and he wants to win no matter what even
if we have to terminate the Constitution
okay that's what he's saying there
that's what he was saying on January 6
folks that's what the whole point was of
hey Mike Pence better do what I want him
to do which is make sure to terminate
all the rules and regulations and
articles even those found in the
Constitution right that's what he was
saying you dumb [ __ ] he's been
saying for years he just didn't type it
out like this okay he goes on there's
more to this [ __ ]
our great here's what he says our great
quote Founders again
he's not using the quotes right they
just don't get it right most the time
yeah uh did not want
and would not condone
false and fraudulent elections so
there's a lot of stuff to unpack here in
this tweet I mean he puts the quotes on
the wrong word right that's the first
great great what would be like found
you're not down in the founders you're
saying that they are great they are the
founders like it's fact but if you're
trying to make it say like oh great like
that's where you would put the quotes
but also what I find so funny about this
is the fact that he's like a massive
fraud of this type of Max who allows for
the termination of all rules regulation
and articles even those found in the
Constitution
okay great so we're gonna get rid of the
First Amendment you're gonna get rid of
the Second Amendment that's right yeah
all of them the Fifth Amendment oh I'm
gonna get everything everything so that
means that Republicans are the ones that
are coming after your guns they want to
repeal the Second Amendment they want to
repeal the First Amendment they're
coming after your free speech they're
coming after your guns that would be the
Republican party then I'm just using the
logic that he put out there in a true
social tweet truth [ __ ] whatever that
is truly how they feel by the way yeah
that is truly how to feel I'll show you
proof
um here is uh I forget his name
some [ __ ] cracker he's a [ __ ]
white Republican cracker and some some
[ __ ] politician elected somewhere
he's on um also if they I just want to
point this out if they do
terminate the Constitution then Joe
Biden would in theory be able to stay in
his position wouldn't he just be the
dictator limits yeah when they're doing
great I mean he's the one that has the
power over the [ __ ] military if if
there is no if there is no uh uh term
limit to say that
a president can only serve two terms two
four-year terms right at that point then
you're like okay then this person stays
in power you dumb [ __ ] idiots it's
like the people who are like well you
gotta impeach him okay then Harris comes
in you gotta impeach him well then
Pelosi comes in you guys don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about and when
you do say it it makes you look even
more dumb but if you want to continue
with this idea of oh we should totally
terminate or suspend the Constitution
okay fine see what happens like right
every Amendment you love and every rule
you think applies to you is no longer in
effect so if you want fascism and a
dictatorship
and you you it's like the
self-fulfilling really weird [ __ ] it's
really weird [ __ ] man because they they
act like we're some kind of worshipers
of [ __ ] Democrats and Joe Biden or
something
like listen
I I think Joe Biden is one of the most
effective presidents that we've had in a
long time yeah to be quite honest he's
very effective whether you like it or
you don't like it you like his policies
you know there's a lot of Democrats that
don't think he goes far enough but the
only reason why they don't think he goes
far enough is because he's effective in
the way that he operates meaning he's
getting stuff he's just not going as far
as they want him to go right they're not
mad that Joe Biden's not doing something
they're mad he's not he he's not
negotiating high enough which I mean
maybe there's an argument to be made
there we're not gonna [ __ ] talk about
that because we got [ __ ] Nazis
banging at the door and and [ __ ] boxes
like this [ __ ] idiot here Grandpa
cracker what's his name what's his name
here what's this guy's name ah where the
[ __ ] is his name
they don't even put his name on here
that's how Irrelevant this guy is I
don't know who this guy is anyways he's
some elected official somewhere and and
George Stephanie I would the way I look
at these people are and I have a
breaking news announcement after
interviewing it's in connection with
this so we can play the clicking but
yeah sure the people that say these
things or the people that you know go on
these shows we should suspend this the
dumbest these people who are like I'm a
constitutionalist shut the [ __ ] up man
look yeah do my pocket Constitution
right here their their only moment
in the Limelight that they can get
they'll take it right because all they
want to do is they want to say oh yeah I
have my 15 minutes of fame it's why all
these Republicans vote the way they do
so they can get their 15 you know 15
seconds of an interview like sound bite
on Fox News and get that play to play to
play and play and played to be like I'm
relevant see I was on here and I did
this interview and I made this dumbass
comment
well and and the other thing too about
this clip here and I don't know what you
got breaking news clip-wise but this
clip here it only exposes the reason why
they they capitulate to Trump is because
it's all about their power and it ain't
about the Constitution it ain't about
people it ain't about the country it
ain't about the military it ain't about
rights Liberty Freedom they don't give a
[ __ ] about any of that they just want to
be white and they want to be in control
and they want their power that's what
they [ __ ] want that's what they
desire the most and the reason why is
because it allows them to continue doing
what they're doing in their little
[ __ ] white little world that they
live in and it's the truth you don't
like it [ __ ] you it's all about white
supremacy the whole [ __ ] thing if how
do you think it happened in Nazi Germany
in Nazi Germany it wasn't just Hitler
who had this idea and he took over the
entire country it took a lot of people
in the country to go you know what it's
not that bad no big deal yeah you know
look the other way you know he ain't
gonna come after me he's gonna come
after me but watch this that's what they
think that's right that's what he that's
what this [ __ ] idiot thinks watch uh
the economy is stable and they have the
jobs to be able to live and take care of
their family Donald Trump was your
nominee in 2016 and 2020 you voted for
him in 2016 and 2020 now he's talking
about suspending the Constitution can
you support a candidate in 2024 who's
for suspending the Constitution well
again it's early I think there's going
to be a lot of people in the primary I
think at the end of the day uh you will
say whoever the Republican then to pick
I'll fall in behind because that's even
if it's Donald Trump as he's called for
suspending the Constitution well again I
think it's yes yes the answer is yes yes
he will support Donald Trump vigorously
even though Donald Trump will Advocate
to suspend the Constitution like he did
over the weekend and he did on January
6th in fact on January 6 he went a lot
further than what he did over the
weekend January 6 he was directing
people to do to take certain actions to
subvert our Constitution and terminate
our constitution by the way I think
that's what Jack Smith is doing right
now as we speak
as we speak [ __ ] is doing his
work
um but again George stephanopoul is here
it's amazing this guy would say this out
loud or capitulate out loud like this
and George tries to call him on here I
don't think he goes far enough I'll show
you why it's gonna be a big field I
don't think Donald Trump's going to
clear out the field like he did in the
six that's not what I'm asking I'm
asking you if he's the nominee will you
support him uh I will support whoever
the Republican nominee is
and I just don't think that at this
point he'll be able to get there because
I think there's a lot of other good
quality candidates he will get there by
the way yeah you'd support a candidate
who's come out for suspending the
Constitution
well you know he says a lot of things uh
you have to take him in context and
right now
I have to worry about making sure his
Republican governance group and the
Republican majority that we make things
work for American people and I can't be
uh really chasing every one of these
crazy statements that come out about for
many of these candidates at the moment
but that's an extraordinary statement
you can't come out against someone who's
for suspending the Constitution
well first off it has no ability to
suspend the Constitution secondly he
says he's for it Dave Joyce is who this
guy is uh representative Dave Joyce I
don't know aware of he's the Republican
governance group chair here's the thing
George Staffing monopolis tries here a
little bit more now I'll show it but
George staff and opposed should look
this guy in the eyes and say look you
are the Republican governance group
chair you are elected official in this
country in the Republican Party a which
Donald Trump is trying to seek
denomination sir you are on a national
media program right now in front of the
entire nation and what you are telling
me is that you will you will support
someone who is in favor
of of terminating the constitution in
which you were in which is the way you
were elected sir if you do not give me a
yes or no right now that you are willing
to vote and support someone who is
willing to terminate and suspend the
Constitution you will never be invited
back on this program because because we
will take it that you are a treasonous
piece of garbage is exactly what the
media should be saying this [ __ ]
light-footed oh there's both sides there
is no both sides to this there is no
both sides to terminate the Constitution
because you're butt hurt there is not a
[ __ ] another side to that but let's
listen to how George wraps it up well
you know he says a lot of things that uh
uh but that doesn't mean that it's ever
going to happen so you got to accept uh
exact fact from fantasy and fantasy is
that the we're going to suspend the
Constitution and go backwards we're
moving forward and we're going to
continue to move forward as a republican
majority and as a republican conference
I don't see how you can move forward if
your candidate is for suspending the
Constitution but thank you for your time
no I mean they can't move forward
especially when you've got a group like
the Republicans who are trying to remove
every right that women or people of
color have they don't want same-sex
marriage they don't want interracial
marriage they don't want women to have a
bodily autonomy that is the Republican
Party they're already moving backward
right they're already regressing in the
in the the points that they have or the
views that they have but all or at least
publicly uh that they have right because
we know obviously they have those those
views and those those ideologies
privately
it's just how they sew them into our
um
our democracy in our country but the
thing I do want to point out here is the
guy what everyone is doing it's the same
reason why they won't call out Trump
specifically Trump on the anti-Semitism
and having dinner over the Thanksgiving
weekend with Kanye and Nick Fuentes
they're future proofing it's why even
Ben Shapiro who is Jewish will not call
out Trump he's like oh well the best way
not to have dinner with the violent
racist anti-semite is to not have dinner
with the violent anti-racist semi well
here's the thing who are you talking
about we know who you're talking about
right but why not say the name because
you're afraid if you say Trump and you
call him out for having dinner with an
anti-semitic white nationalist white
supremacist Nazi
that you're going to have to eat those
words later on when and if he becomes
the next nominee for the 2024 election
and when the party decides to turn
around and say oh yes the guy that did
try to overthrow the government and and
throw a coup and do all these things in
terms of try to destroy our democracy oh
yeah we actually we actually want that
guy back in power the guy that wants to
take away these rights the guy that
wants to decide that he's the ultimate
ruler and wants to to to terminate the
Constitution and that's what Dave Joyce
who is from Ohio by the way oh okay
wants to do he's future proofing himself
to say well in this I didn't say I wow
right I didn't I never said Trump I
wouldn't I just don't want to support
him right now right because he you know
what he's gonna lose he says you know he
says some crazy things he's just that
old crazy you know like that old crazy
uncle we but we love him well that's the
other thing I want to say is that look
he keep he kept saying he says things he
says things no that it's not true I sat
I sat through how many hours was the
January 6 Select Committee of coverage
that we sat through we watched every 45
Plus hours we sat through the entirety
of it we watched every single moment
that happened and let me tell you
something it wasn't just talk it was not
just talk it was not just post on a
social media site they were actively
trying to suspend and terminate and get
rid of our constitution there was just a
trial it was just a trial where that
leader of The Oath Keepers and several
other members were charged and convicted
by a jury of sedition sedition of our
constitution
and Donald Trump was implicated in that
sedition in the trial they were doing it
on his best for crying out loud yeah
it's it is uh
it is insane it is insane that this is
the this is the dumb timeline we live in
uh but on a on a related note to
election and certification of a free and
fair election despite Republicans trying
to suppress or
um uh uh cause an unfair or
um you know rather or or what I mean to
say is basically rig the system cheat
the game right that's what they want to
do and In This Moment
people came out they saw the threat that
there was and they voted for Katie Hobbs
now Republicans are obviously mad so is
Trump so is you know Kerry Lake but
that's how it is oops
it happens and it's official and
breaking Mark Elias has it and Arizona's
officials canvas and certify
State results so it's done
it's done and there's not going to be
any changing it there's not going to be
going back a matter of fact apparently
this morning there's news of Rudy
Giuliani apparently there's a hearing
this morning of suspending his law
license
um in D.C over over the 2020 stuff which
they're headed down the same road in the
Arizona election because there is there
they are doing the same thing they are
committing the fraud you cannot claim
election fraud fraudulently it's not a
thing you can do you have to have
evidence you have to have proof you
can't just say well we don't agree we
want to win and it's fraud because we
want to win that's not how it [ __ ]
works in courts in the real world and
that's the trouble that these people are
going to have but that's the turmoil
that we're under and that's why they
[ __ ] believe this stupid Twitter
files thing
um
um let's go back to that finally yeah
yeah let's jump into so so where do you
want to start do you want to I want to
start actual threat or do you want to
start with who did the threat or where
do you want no no I'll start with uh
here we'll we'll start with this because
it's relevant to what's going on right
now
okay this is where it all started okay
this is uh this is the next day after
Kanye gets suspended permanently from
Twitter after sharing a uh a swastika
inside the Star of David this is the
next the next day this comes out right
it's like oh how convenient you and what
I believe is happening here is Elon Musk
makes his announcement that the Twitter
files are coming out this this this
[ __ ] expose a is gonna [ __ ] reveal
all of this uh colluding and uh uh just
suppression campaign of the hunter Biden
dick pic laptop story that's that's
what's going on okay this is where it
starts
this is the second of December so this
one yeah yeah so you've got the CEO
slash owner the chief [ __ ] putting out
this tweet to say what really happened
with the hunter Biden story suppression
by Twitter will be will be published on
Twitter at 5 PM Eastern then as you
scroll down
he goes uh this will be awesome yay
popcorn
and then I think it's awesome because
he's excited to get the dick pics out
there again well so there's more because
they were I'll explain in a little bit
so uh yeah he's probably a little
excited who knows so then you have a
tweet later on now at this point I think
the Tweet uh was like five
30 or so maybe something like that
um or 5 20. so he was it was going to be
5 p.m Eastern 5 p.m Eastern and so I
mean if you look at the actual if you
click into the we're double checking
some facts
421 oh that's so 520 5 21 p.m Eastern
like nine minutes but our our 20 20 21
minutes after when it's supposed to
start he goes oops my bad it's gonna
start in 40 minutes we got to do some
last minute double checking on some
facts the fact that you didn't do the
fact checking before
5 p.m Eastern really tells me that one
you guys are scrambling and you're
trying to put some pieces together and
make it all seem like it's a big big
problem right well here's the other
thing about fact checking is they
actually released emails from Twitter
employees they did not check with these
Twitter employees about these emails
beforehand they did not fact check
because what you would do as a
journalist and I'm not one but what you
would do as a journalist if you were any
had any sort of credibility is you would
go to the parties in question of the
email to find out if this was legitimate
to find out if this is really what and
you would fact check that you would make
sure that it it both sides on the email
were like yes that's a that's a real
email yeah and you would do it through
either them their PR or their lawyer
that's how you would fact check this
stuff but they they obviously did not do
any of that what is this next link so
this is where it all starts right
because now it's it the actual they
actually you mean with with Elon Musk
This Is Where It Starts yeah so this
next one is where Matt Tybee says
the the Twitter files this is where it
all starts right this is the massive
thread that puts Seth Abrams in to shame
you know
um also I've never seen Seth Abramson
and Matt Ty be in the same room together
well you never know yeah right I don't
know so it's now 5 34 p.m which means at
6 34 p.m eastern time so now they're an
hour and a half late I mean people like
Don Jr were were questioning they're
like it's 90 minutes after one they said
it was going to happen has anyone
checked if he's okay if anyone checked
this Clinton's and all this nonsense and
and nobody knew other than Elon uh I
guess that that Matt was going to be
doing this everyone assumed that Elon
was going to be the one that was going
to release this stuff he was going to
release his treasure but don't you think
yeah but don't you think that's because
he doesn't want personal liability here
that he's trying to push it off on
someone who may appear to be a
journalist and this is the yeah that he
could get to [ __ ] anything like this
yeah and I think that is very much part
of it you know there's like oh plausible
deniability or whatever but it's like if
you're hyping up this thing and be like
it's gonna be awesome popcorn you know
if you're doing that then that assumes
that
yeah we know we know that you you gave
this stuff to them because you get it
well the reason why we know is because
mantaiibi on his [ __ ] blog said that
there were conditions that Elon gave him
literally the thing that they accused
Democrats of in the media of in this
[ __ ] thread they were doing for this
thread right like the exact thing like
you can't we're not we're going to
suppress what the actual story is you
can only release it on certain
conditions like you're doing exactly
what you're accusing them of doing in
the thread that it's [ __ ] weird but
let's let's go down the thread here for
so okay okay you can scroll past all
this [ __ ] because this is a bunch of
explanations he's going okay all right
so now he goes seven tweets deep to
build a backstory when he could have
just like Hunter Biden deep Hunter Biden
deep right okay I'm just making sure
exactly so now he actually gets into
something of like substance to talk
about right so he says by 2020 requests
from connected actors to delete tweets
were routine one executive would write
to another more review from the Biden
team they'll probably come back handled
this is okay all right
they were thinking this was going to be
some bombshell right this was not a
bombshell what this actually ended up
showing us was that there was a protocol
in place if people were to report tweets
now which anyone can do right anyone can
anyone can report a tweet yeah right you
can you can report a tweet on Twitter
you can go through the process now if
you already have a back and forth with
Twitter right if you already have a uh
you're already a case File if you
already have a case File then you can
say hey here are more that are in
connection with that okay you can email
with that cage file right right you can
email right and if you haven't let's say
that you do have a contact to Twitter
you could very easily say like hey I
want to do this and like they will tell
you sure I can follow up but it's best
if you file a report right and then we
can actually track this because if not
it's just in an email so this is in
addition to an already existing report
that's happening right well and I want
to point out that Matt taibi if you look
at the email here he has removed what
appears to be removed the important
information that would that would reveal
who this email was right to him he just
says oh it's an executive it's an
executive right okay great so an
executive was alerted about something
and there was an existing case file on a
report that's saying like oh there are
these there are these images or these
videos that are being shared without
permission from this person which I
don't know if and these are these are
the five posts here right yeah these are
five that are in there so and if you if
you look at these I mean I can I can try
and find the ones that expose them
because you can uh and when I say expose
I mean like they just went to internet
archive and they looked at the archived
version of these tweets so anyone can do
that if you want to look these up feel
free you won't find anything that's like
oh my God because there's nothing that's
like oh my God it's just images of
Hunter Biden that were shared without
permission right the same reason and
mainly of his [ __ ] right exactly and the
same reason that if you have your
private photos let's say you took a dick
pic or you made it a video or you were
doing this or doing that and you had a
computer that had these things on them
if it was taken from that computer and
then posted online without permission
and then people were sharing because it
was a it was a campaign to come against
you right to attack you and as a result
obviously attack your father who's
running for president not president who
is running for president right this is
October 24th he hasn't even been elected
yet he is running he is a candidate he
has not been elected he has not been uh
sworn in as president he is just a
candidate who has I think at this point
probably done two of the debates one of
which Trump came in knowing he had
coveted but but wait a second but what
does what does five post of Hunter
Biden's [ __ ] have to do with Joe Biden
not being able to be president it has
nothing to do I don't know what is i
that's what I'm trying to figure out
here like what what is the bombshell
here is that these posts were removed of
Hunter Biden's [ __ ] that have nothing to
do nothing to do with barisma or Ukraine
or China or Joe Biden at all it's just
pictures of Hunter Biden's [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does that have to do it's with with
why why it's collusion to Barry a story
there's nothing there's nothing crazy
about it there's nothing like oh my God
this is a bombshell like even yeah I
mean he was people he was taking
pictures of himself smoking crack and
having sex with prostitutes on his
personal devices why in the world would
you believe that there weren't pictures
of Hunter Biden's [ __ ] on his personal
devices yeah I don't understand what the
big bombshell is here that Hunter Biden
likes to take stupid pictures I don't
understand this what the [ __ ] there's
there's nothing I mean here here throw
out the whole uh debate of personal
privacy the thing that Republicans love
to say oh my privacy right right this is
what my you can't take these things
right all right fine so you think that
it applies to you but not other people I
mean literally what this is
you could file this under revenge porn
right these are images taken taken
without permission and posted online in
the state of California they've just
passed a law that says revenge porn you
can be sued up to thirty thousand
dollars I don't know if that's for every
instance of it but now women
can take uh unsolicited dick pics that
you send them
and they can sue you because they never
ask for it and they didn't want it to be
so revenge porn is a thing that's in
other states as well but I I
specifically sorry in California if you
can send unsolicited dick pics you can
get sued up to thirty thousand dollars
so good luck dudes good luck I hope you
I hope you go along with that but this
is just again I guess it's all it is
again and I'm not opposed to anyone
looking at [ __ ] pictures of [ __ ] if
that's what floats your boat yeah that's
totally fine whatever whatever but I
still do not see what what this has to
do with the presidential campaign other
than the the Biden team because these
people are claiming who it is the
bindings like hey this breaks your terms
of service and they're claiming it's
Hunter Biden and they're trying to use
it against us which it has nothing to do
with us and if it is Hunter Biden it
probably needs to be taken down because
there's no consent right right and it's
just the Biden Administration all right
excuse me the Biden campaign who became
the bind Administration right yeah
running a resident now running again we
had not even had the
they're just filing a report which
anyone can do on Twitter for any tweet
you you can file a report about any
Tweet now rather they take it down or
not that that's up to them
um now they're really focusing on the
handle this thing yeah but obviously the
handle this is hey we took these down
because yes they do break our terms of
service now what's this next one that
they're talking about here so the next
one in here and the one that everyone
got so [ __ ] obsessed about right and
also uh James Woods so James Woods
shared an image and I'll see if I can
find the image specifically uh that was
taken down and it's it's him
when he was when
when he was brought up in this thing
everyone's like oh my God James Woods he
went on a Tucker Carlson that night and
made this crazy statement
he said
the DNC
because it says here it says like oh
it's a report from the additional or
whatever it says support from the DNC
so now this whole idea is that the DNC
is colluding with Twitter to take down
these votes and suppress your First
Amendment right well again
Twitter is not the government Twitter is
a private company right it has terms of
service that when you go through and
whether you read it or not I mean let's
be honest nobody reads the terms of
service but if you do read the terms of
service it'll probably say something
along the lines of uh you can't post
pornography especially pornography
against you know without permission
other photos of other people without
permission I mean there's literally when
you go through the reporting process
you can say that these images are of me
or my likeness and they were posted
without permission so what's happening
here is they say oh here's an additional
report they're just throwing in the
tweets because again it's of an existing
case that's been opened about hey
there's a bunch of photos or videos
posted without permission of Hunter
Biden on Twitter so we might as well
flag all of these to to make sure that
we have them handled right handled I'm
gonna go take out the trash handled like
these are just normal responses but when
someone goes handled like it's the big
[ __ ] Smoking Gun and all this but
what James Woods did here was he shared
a photo of Hunter Biden he was smoking
crack and they redid it of um
him naked I think there's a woman that's
in the photo blurred out a little bit uh
and the thing says uh I'm with
uh Team toe right and it's a joke of of
Joe Biden and it says like I'm with I'm
with toe or whatever the [ __ ] it said
and it was using the Joe Biden logo and
he was saying like call this number you
know all this stuff of like how to
support Joe Biden that is what he was
using and that is what he was sharing he
shared some other stuff too but that was
the one this is James Woods this is
James Woods the the actor and I use
those quotes correctly here the actor
James Woods now is so upset because he
says oh the DNC and Twitter have
destroyed my career oh Jesus okay here's
the thing you had to have a career to
begin with well the other thing too is
this is the same Kanye [ __ ] this is the
same thing like you did this you posted
it yeah who forced who held down James
Wood and forced him to post this on his
Twitter account
[Music]
so he is saying that he posted this yeah
yeah it's it's ridiculous and and so
they get mad they they play they play
victim and say
well no no no no no I was the one who
who's the victim here because they took
down the thing that it was illegal I
mean literally if if you look at the
terms of service it says None
consensually produced or distributed
explicit images or videos
non-consensually produced or distributed
explicit images or videos so for fake
Gabe out there who I know has a private
collection because he shared that
[ __ ] website of where you can find
these images has been
all day long it must have been choking
the old chicken to Hunter Biden's house
it is insane again one Joe Biden was not
the president in 2020.
what the hell what the hell does Hunter
Biden's salacious photos off his laptop
have to do with Joe Biden being present
I still do not understand this here's
the other reason because he's next
tweets right and number 10 here in the
in the thread Matt taibi says both
parties okay yep let's listen up they
gave both parties had access to these
tools which the tools they're talking
about are the reporting tools which
everyone has access nobody nobody has
new Advanced tools that have access to
it the only same report tweet the only
difference is is that the campaigns more
than likely had a liaison at Twitter so
that they wouldn't have to they could
actually because there's a ton of [ __ ]
to report I'm sure I mean that may be
the only salacious thing but again Matt
Tye is saying you're both parties
meaning Trump and Biden in this instance
again he goes on to say for instance in
2020 requests from both get this Gabe
the Trump White House which is the um
what is the White House what what branch
of um do you call that government is the
White House the executive branch oh okay
so it is so he was the president so
Trump was the government okay so again
metabe says requests from both the Trump
White House and the Biden Campaign which
is not the government were received and
honored
so in other words there is no story here
because we don't get to see as the
public for our free and fair information
of the request
that were taken from the Trump White
House and handled by Twitter and that is
the reason why that is the reason why
this is just they are doing what they
are accusing the Democrats in the media
doing in this exact thread that they are
suppressing information that would
likely give you a good clear picture of
what the information they're claiming
they have with these dick pics and again
it is the it is all projection and this
is the reason why Matt taibi is a
[ __ ] joke no one should ever consider
him being a journalist ever again he
should absolutely be 86th into the the
bin of media because this guy's a
[ __ ] joke in this in this one tweet
here he ruined his entire credibility
his entire credibility because then he
says however however
this system wasn't balanced is the next
is the next tweet it was based on
contacts because Twitter was and is
overwhelmingly staffed with people one
political orientation what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with anything
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything there is no dumb argument that
he's trying to make so so you're telling
me true social when they're hiring
they're they don't hire people of more
one political orientation than the other
are you telling me that is that what
you're saying here's the thing though I
mean like with truth social you you work
for truth social under the idea that is
a Conservative Republican company
right now I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
really spoil fake games a little little
Theory here and also Matt taibi I lived
in San Francisco right I didn't move to
San Francisco because I'm a liberal okay
if anything living there and moving to
La like I would say I probably moved
even more left on the spectrum of the of
the political kind of aisle but what I
would say is
it I didn't move there because it was
liberal I've moved there for [ __ ]
Tech I worked in Tech that's what a job
I mean a career
and that is that is that is what I
decided to do right because I felt my
best opportunity was in the Bay Area
because that was the tech Hub now
people go there they were for companies
like Twitter
you would probably find because the Bay
Area is more liberal or more Progressive
you'll find obviously a larger amount of
people who work at a company because the
pool that you're hiring from already has
those people they're not going to the
company saying that's a liberal company
and I'm gonna work for that liberal
company now you could maybe argue
there's probably a couple people
whatever but you don't have an
overwhelming majority of people that go
I'm a liberal and I'm gonna go work for
Twitter
that's not it at all versus somebody who
goes I'm conservative and I want to go
work I'm a Nazi I'm a Nazi I want to go
work for True social because you don't
see a liberal walking in the door
wherever that company is non-existent
wherever that company is around and says
oh yeah truth social I'm a liberal and I
want to work there [ __ ] no you don't I
can I can tell you right now
the people who worked at Twitter there
were liberals there were conservatives
and you better believe it they were
[ __ ] Libertarians because there's a
ton of Libertarians in the Bay area as
well as there's a ton of conservatives
there's a ton of Republicans there are a
ton of Maga people who worked at Twitter
as well as liberal he's pulling
donations based on who their political
affiliation with was with at Twitter and
they're saying oh well because there was
a larger pool of liberals in the Bay
Area that they were hired from so if you
have a larger group of course you're
going to find more of those people
there's still other people still exist
but you find more of those people in the
school so if you hire from then they
might have a greater number of of
applicants and also employees that were
hired that are Democrat or at least
that's how they were registered but
here's the thing is that you know
because I'm going to show this
contributions by party of recipient
because uh the Manti be posted this as
if this has anything to do with anything
it is it is everyone's free right to
contribute to a campaign you have the
Liberty you have the freedom to choose
who you want to contribute to now the
fact that smart tech people are liberals
is not an indication of their liberalism
it's only an indication probably of
their [ __ ] intelligence would be my
guess that's just me but here it shows
in 2022 they're all excited because
the amount that was donated to Democrats
was 99 and 2020 was 98 and 2018 it was
96. there's not much of a margin there
it's the same thing meaning this wasn't
something that just happened in 2020 and
it was collusion it happened before it
happened after and it's it's their free
right to contribute I've I've been docs
Gabe online and one of the things that
they doxed me for
I said I gave to Democrats as well how
much did you give to Democrats though
how much did I give to Democrats in 2020
I think I gave something like 500 bucks
or something oh my God Tony right but
here's the thing here's the craziest
part about this would anyone [ __ ]
would anyone imagine that I would give
my money to Democrats like how how is
that even [ __ ] news how is that even
news that I would give my hard-earned
money to a Democrat you would think when
I go on my show and tell my audience hey
if you got some spare change give it
directly to the candidates and I gave
directly to the candidates I didn't give
the super Pacs I gave directly to the
candidates on through their act blue
it's a thing you go out and look at it
it's document oh my god
um it's my [ __ ] free right it's my
Liberty you stupid [ __ ] to give to
candidates just like people who work at
Twitter and earn money at Twitter have
the right and the freedom to give to
whoever they want and just because
they're not giving to your candidate
only shows your fascism that you're mad
that they aren't forced to give to who
you want them to give to you do not
believe in Freedom you do not believe in
Liberty and just because a big tech
company who is one of the biggest social
media companies in the world hires some
of the best smartest and brightest
people in Tech they ended up being
liberal what does that tell you about
conservatism maybe maybe you should look
internally you dumb [ __ ] but I
mean it's just me you know what am I
gonna and I also you know I have a I
have a question that I've asked on
Twitter before
um you know one can you show me and fake
Gabe feel free to to answer these
questions in the chat one show me one
website or app that has been designed
and built that is not a complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] show and is done well not copy
paste not true social copying Twitter
anything like that and in addition show
me a comedian in on the right who is a
republican that actually is [ __ ]
funny okay
either one of these things show you that
there's no sense of creativity there's
no sense of
uh uh Innovation there's no sense of of
of actually uh
uh of using skills to create what you
find is you've got conservatives and
Republicans Maga whatever that just copy
paste take them with someone else's idea
steal it claim credit like Elon Musk
says that he invented the [ __ ] rocket
and and created the electric car and I'm
sure later on he'll rewrite the history
of Twitter and say he was the one that
started it
and so you've got a guy here that's that
it has another dude Matt taibi pushing
the story on how Twitter was actually
suppressing the First Amendment
violating the First Amendment from the
government
big no on that because that did not
happen
well here you have him talking because
this is this is the part that fake gay
wants us to talk about it took 16 tweets
to get to get to the lab story right the
laptop part which again number 16 in the
thread the Twitter files part one we're
already we're at 16 he's already in part
one and he's already admitted that both
both parties had access were doing this
yeah now uh because again
uh Michael Cohen went to prison to
suppress a hush money payment story that
Donald Trump did not want to come out in
2016. so
um excuse me while I say [ __ ] you about
the whole they are hiding the hunter
Biden lamp top story because let me tell
you why they were hiding the hunter
Biden laptop story fake Gabe is because
it wasn't an actual story Okay the
reason why the reason why no one wanted
to run with the hunter Biden laptop
story because no one had the laptop it
they did not have the [ __ ] laptop it
was copies and it was and and Gabe will
tell you more about this than I will
because he understands
tainted [ __ ] tainted [ __ ] hard
drives but these hard drives were not
the original hard drives they were not
they were not the original hard drives
they were copies of copies of copies
they were making claims all these hard
drives were [ __ ] different the reason
why fake game that the FBI will never
charge listen to me when I say this they
will never charge Hunter Biden for that
laptop is because of you morons on the
right you morons on the right you wanted
to this so [ __ ] bad and you guys
tainted this story so [ __ ] much with
your nonsense that they would never be
able to charge Hunter Biden because they
don't have the original [ __ ] hard
drives and they don't have a laptop
because it doesn't exist sure they were
sure they were what what what is this
what is he saying now sure they were
because this is the part that the magas
want us to talk about right they want us
they want us to [ __ ] give them a good
reason why why the Smoking Gun emails
here's the New Yorker Smoking Gun emails
reveals how 100 are Biden they posted
the story on the internet
they posted the story on the internet
the problem is the Smoking Gun emails
that that you claim are real you don't
know if they're real or not you have no
idea if they are real go ahead Gabe I'll
give you the yeah so what Tony brings up
is a good point and we've heard it more
and more from other people like uh Matt
Gates who enters into the official
record I've got the contents of Hunter
Biden's laptop on my thumb drive okay
you've got people with random thumb
drives you've got people who have access
to emails you've got people who had this
laptop and that laptop and this laptop
the laptop had a laptop baby and that
laptop had the dick pics on it are we
gonna have Hunter Biden's laptop or
release a statement today or not I don't
know uh who knows I mean yeah
you might see it you might not I
wouldn't be surprised if Hunter Biden's
laptop was
was formulating uh a a an announcement
to make but here's the thing you've got
all these people like you can track back
and find you know where the digital foot
or like the fingerprints are but if you
got a ton of people that are like I got
the contents I got the contents I got
the laptop I got it there's only one
contents there's only one there's only
one and if what you claim is true fate
Gabe that the FBI has it then what are
you so [ __ ] butt hurt about why are
you so [ __ ] butt hurt the reason the
reason why you're so butt hurt is
because it's not going to tell the story
that you want to tell so what you guys
had to do was steal the contents of the
laptop which is what happened and you
modified it and used it to your own
narrative to [ __ ] talk about Hunter
Biden that has nothing to do with Joe
Biden because we talk about Trump's
children because they are corrupt they
run his organization which is under
criminal [ __ ] trial right now and
civil [ __ ] trial and receivership in
New York City they they they the Trump
children not only [ __ ] campaigned and
behest of him and for him they were paid
Kimberly Guilford and Donald Trump were
paid paid money and and you [ __ ]
his children were in the white house
with Ivanka and Jared you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] really
are out of your [ __ ] minds and Matt
taibi what what a shame because this guy
used to be a journalist before he went
off to Moscow and I'm sure Putin got
[ __ ] dirt on him I'm sure that
there's [ __ ] videotape of him doing
God knows what pissing on who knows what
bed and that and that's why Matt taibi
has to [ __ ] play this stupid game
like he's still a journalist or
something but here in 18 18 here goes
Twitter took extraordinary steps to
suspect suppress the story because it
wasn't real it was [ __ ] it was
misinformation it was lies removing
links and post warning that it would be
unsafe
they even blocked the termination Viva
direct message
again because
there is [ __ ] non-consensual photos
in this thing because you people are
getting obsessed with [ __ ] that isn't
real and it's misinformation that is the
reason why they quote unquote suppress
the story just like they Shadow ban all
kinds of [ __ ] and the fact that you
people don't understand that social
media and Shadow Banning is a thing and
it is a thing they can do regardless of
what you want and your freedom of speech
it is their freedom of speech it's their
platform they own it it is their freedom
of speech to Shadow ban whatever the
[ __ ] they want they Shadow ban porn
right now they Shadow ban porn account
porn exists on Twitter consensual porn
exists on Twitter it's all over the
place you can post Nudes on Twitter and
they won't take them down as long as
it's consensual but they will Shadow ban
it now again I don't I don't understand
why they think Shadow Banning is is
[ __ ] is
is in any way
election tampering they had the ability
to suppress anything they want I I've
experienced this before and we've
experienced it live on air where they
take a certain topic that's trending
right and it may be a hashtag and
Twitter literally changes what that
trend is in real time almost
instantaneously because what they're
doing is they're suppressing the actual
hashtag or the actual words and they're
trying to change the trend because
they're Shadow Banning suppressing and
they can do that the reason why they can
do that is it's their [ __ ] website
fake game
um and it goes on that Kaylee mcinany
was locked at her account for tweeting
the story
um of course you were
um they have their foot also again it
comes back to the idea that like okay
you've got Kaylee mcinany who at the
time was press secretary for Trump
government government government
government
what exactly is the reason that a
government official would be tweeting a
story about a stolen laptop that had
naked photos of uh the the candidate's
son if you were not trying to use it to
spread misinformation as a government
official yeah like why why are you why
are you sharing porn right why are you
sharing uh photos and videos of someone
that were non-consensual again they like
how big his [ __ ] is apparently
it's [ __ ] weird man like the
obsession with people's genitalia and
also children like you guys are goddamn
[ __ ] creeps and I just want to bring
it back to James Woods okay James Woods
is 75 years old okay
how old do you think his wife is
or his uh his his partner that uh he
engaged he proposed to
how old do I think his wife is I have no
idea I I don't do you think that she is
uh older than half his age or younger I
would say younger probably younger she
is 33 years old now I'm not saying there
you know you could date whatever you
want to do right you above the age of
consent you're being an Aegis now
I know what I'm saying is
In This Moment you've got a really old
dude
in a relationship with a a girl who's 33
75 33 that's 44 or 42 years age
difference now again above the age of
consent you could take whatever do all
those things but for a group that wants
to talk about older man creeping on
younger women and obsessed with
pedophilia and they're obsessed with
grooming and they're obsessed with uh uh
being these Christianity genitalia in
general it's weird I mean again it's all
projection so it all really comes back
to this idea that
they got really upset that they weren't
allowed to share dick pics from Hunter
Biden and the person that got really
upset was James Woods who again went
into Tucker Carlson and said I'm gonna
sue the DNC and Twitter for colluding to
destroy my career I'm not even a
celebrity anymore for what they did to
me
be over a tweet mind you over one tweet
he's blaming that the destruction of his
career was because one tweet he shared
about a naked Hunter Biden in connection
with Joe Biden's campaign and they said
oh we can't have that on on the platform
so they took it down it was reported and
so he says from that one tweet his
career was destroyed I highly doubt a
career who even gives a [ __ ] about James
Woods in the first place right honestly
but it's all a it's all someone trying
to stay relevant and like oh man you
know cancer culture and funny answers
when I share this dick pic of another
dude that's gonna [ __ ] own his dad
okay I don't understand I still don't
understand why they thought sharing dick
pics of Hunter Biden was going to hurt
Joe Biden it's why did they think that
was why because it's a it's you know
kitchen sink approach you gotta throw
anything in there you've got the October
surprise that's the best they had was
Hunter Biden likes to take pictures of
his [ __ ] this is ridiculous this is that
was the best they have okay so here's
here's the end of this whole thing this
thread
um here's the end of it here's his
conclusion as it were this is his
best-selling argument Matt taibi the
person who is supposed to break this
Twitter files and this is going to break
wide open democracy and and transparency
and [ __ ] here it is an amazing subplot
of the Twitter slash Hunter Biden lamp
dop affair was how much was done without
the knowledge of CEO Jack Dorsey and how
long it took the situation to get quote
unfucked as one ex-employee put it even
after Dorsey jumped in why in the [ __ ]
why again this this idea that Jack
Dorsey had no clue about this absolutely
breaks up their entire argument that the
tech company at its core was trying to
[ __ ] subvert elections and trying to
[ __ ] undermine elections if if if the
company itself was trying to interfere
in an election you would believe that
the CEO would be at the helmet at the
direction of it because Jack Dorsey had
no [ __ ] clue folks this is simple
they were reporting tweets that were a
[ __ ] naked photos a hunter Biden that
they did not have consent to [ __ ]
post that is what they were doing also
the Twitter Twitter and their moderation
team believed that the [ __ ] Hunter Biden
laptop story that the New York Post at
best a tabloid was [ __ ] posting was
[ __ ] it was misinformation and
there's libel that could possibly come
of it so they Shadow banned it like they
do all kinds of [ __ ] well not now but
every day every day they suppressed in
Shadow ban [ __ ] and again his [ __ ]
collusion Matt tyb's collusion are a
conclusion here is that the collusion
that they want had nothing to do with
Jack Dorsey the CEO of the company that
they claim was the in big collusion with
the government and the campaign and and
dark cabal whatever the [ __ ] they're
talking about and the CEO hadn't had no
knowledge it is absolutely and here's
here's the thing that people for I guess
people who don't know uh when you work
in a large organization that has
thousands of employees right um I mean
used to used to used to I mean they
still have a a couple thousand you know
when they're not just massive layoffs
um but the way that an organization
works is that you have different
department heads right you've got the
CEO CTO CEO CMO all these different
people who are like Chief Executives or
chief chief level uh uh positions the
higher up twatters right and then you've
got your VPS your svps your managers all
these things right right now there's a
hierarchy of like oh look I'm the head
of this department I am in complete
control the decision here I can work
independently sometimes something might
get involved with another Chief level
person executive person
then you say okay great so you're able
that is a that is a main reason why Jack
Dorsey did not know this was happening
because they said great we've got a team
uh the the content moderation picks why
would why why the [ __ ] okay you gotta
why in the [ __ ] would Twitter employees
at the at a moderation apartment who saw
these pictures knew there was no consent
knew the terms of service why the [ __ ]
would they walk it over and talk to Jack
Dorsey there's no reason to there's no
reason you you as the CEO doesn't make
any sense because here's here's another
a little uh little cluster of uh
business Acumen for fake Gabe when you
build a company right
you have to figure out what is the best
kind of use of your time right I'm the
chief executive you're talking about the
CEO yeah yeah I'm the CEO I'm the chief
executive officer I got a [ __ ] ton of
stuff to deal with I got to deal with
investors I got to deal with this this
this this this I'm getting status
reports from different teams on things
the initiatives that we're working on I
hire people to [ __ ] deal with it
right I hire people to say great I don't
need to micromanage I might be involved
in some things here that might be like a
passion project or whatever but I I have
like uncovering uh Hunter Biden's dick
exactly but I hire people who are
professionals and specialize in that
field to make the right calls and
because they're smart they just happen
to be liberals probably right exactly so
you have this moment where you have
people making decisions and they're
working you got the content moderation
working with trust and safety they're
probably Consulting the legal side of
Council on their company to say we're
going to do this thing is there any
blowback that great boom boom boom boom
boom they make their decisions they go
forward with it maybe in retrospect they
say ah we shouldn't have done it that
way but in the moment based on what they
were seeing they said oh look it seems
like hacked information it's
non-consensual it's pornographic nudity
it's it's it's again it is without
consent
images and videos that were shared on
Twitter it goes against our terms of
service so they said we're gonna
suppress this we're gonna take it out
we're gonna remove them because again
non-consensual images nude of another
person in an attempt to own Biden and
show how he shouldn't be present but you
hire as the CEO people who are going to
deal with it and the reason that Jack
Dorsey didn't know is because he let
those [ __ ] people do their [ __ ]
job right and that is why it's oh my God
it's a big bombshell it's not a
bombshell it's literally how you handle
an organization with thousands of people
Jack Dorsey can't be in India dealing
with customer support he can't be an SF
oh just sitting down at a computer
making sure making sure non-consensual
dick pics are taken you can't he can't
be in the product meeting to be like oh
how do we add this feature into this and
this and this again he might be in some
things here and there but as the CEO
he's getting updates and status reports
he's having all hands with the execs and
other people that are in those roles to
handle those things that he hired them
to do that he can't himself do because
he's only one person there's 24 hours in
a day even if you would say oh this
person doesn't sleep you can't do all of
it you have thousands of employees and
you have millions and millions of tweets
that are sent every every single day
with various amounts of content and in
this instance it was [ __ ] nude images
without consent of another person that
the Republicans love to share and they
get so butthurt that they can't share it
on Twitter
I'm sure was trying to share this stuff
on Facebook and he probably got flagged
and probably got removed wow that's the
other one and they don't like Facebook
either winded says this show sucks ass
thanks for stopping by and then yeah
tomorrow you should come tomorrow too
it's gonna suck ass tomorrow winded
um you know make sure you stop by every
single weekday Monday through Friday I
got one last you got one last uh uh
here's here's what I think that a lot of
people skipped over and there's another
part to it that I just want to add on
Wow but let's this is this is the main
one right this is the main one so it
says number 22 although several sources
recalled hearing about a general warning
from federal law enforcement that uh uh
that that some are about possible
foreign hacks there's no evidence that
I've seen mataibi who has now looked
over this thing for the last 96 hours he
said of any government involvement in
the laptop story in fact that might have
been the problem so again so he's
claiming there one thing and then the
other no evidence that he's seen of any
government involvement in a laptop story
not that there would be because Joe
Biden wasn't the president he wasn't
even elected yet they did not even have
the election yet he was not president in
2020 okay the the person that was
president was President Trump who was
still planning how he was going to
overthrow the government
but the last thing I want to add to this
is over the weekend there was a uh
spaces a Twitter spaces that was held
and I and I was in there for most of the
time
but what's happening is they ask all
these questions about the the the the
Twitter files right and he loves the Q a
thing that yeah it was a q a That was
supposed to happen which they never
released part two they said it was gonna
happen then uh there is no part two well
that's the thing so
uh okay so anyway there's a Twitter
spaces and Elon Musk is in there they're
asking all these questions it was pretty
much filled with right wing Talking
Heads that's all they let talk that's
only people that were on the actually
Michael Cohen got to talk and asked a
couple questions but that was it
everyone else is pretty much right-wing
good Seb Gorka who called this Twitter
file he called it [ __ ] on uh what did
he say he said uh he called it
[Music]
yeah Sebastian Gorka who blocked me I've
never even tweeted about
um he said [ __ ] what did he say he said
essentially it was it was underwhelming
it was a nothing Burger it is a nothing
Burger it's dick pics that they
suppressed and then the laptop story
from the New York Post is a tabloid
story right it's a tabloid story it's
not [ __ ] real it's not based on any
real information it's only based on what
the Republicans want to give and I'll
show you one of them who was at the helm
of it this is Rudy Giuliani apparently
in today's deposition our in today's
hearing where he's gonna get his [ __ ]
long license trip from him watch this is
hilarious this is hilarious watch this
so I'm at a good place to stop Mr chair
thank you
you know I have two watches on
Mr Levin tells you have to something
insane I said we'll try to work on the
microphone uh
so there's Rudy Giuliani he accidentally
that this guy is supposed to know
everything about election fraud and
collusion he's Donald Trump's attorney
he accidentally put two watches on you
don't have two watches on he didn't even
[ __ ] two I got two left shoes on
these are the people they're exp they're
like oh and I saw people that were like
oh Rudy Giuliani was the first one on
the case when it came to the uh the
hunter Biden laptop well didn't he have
it at one point
he got it he got it from the blind
computer tag right and he gave it to the
FBI it already who had already rummaged
through it and and did all kinds of [ __ ]
to it and it's just and and what I was
trying to say earlier is like so you
have this group that's like oh there's
all these [ __ ] on there it's [ __ ]
dick pics in this you guys really
[ __ ] weird you guys are really
[ __ ] weird that you love talking
about look and looking at these things I
love genitalia what they talked about a
part two That was supposed to be coming
out the day after right
and then Elon tweets he goes tune in on
December 2nd he goes tune in for the
Twitter files tomorrow
then on December 3rd he says it looks
like we'll need another day or so
over the weekend he was in his Twitter
spaces and he had revealed multiple
times he goes I haven't read the Twitter
files I gave my Matt taibi uh
unrestricted accent no we didn't because
Matt tyvee admits that he didn't right
and so he says in this Twitter space he
goes oh I gave him full you know
unfettered access if he sees something
that is important he can just post it he
could just post it nope and that's not
true because we know that he had certain
conditions we do know that Matt taibi
doxed uh the personal email yeah for
Jack Dorsey in these files and Elon Musk
oh and he jokes about how they probably
should have better handled that
situation
they have no part two because part two
is a [ __ ] flop If part one was
supposed to be the ooh the nail biter
and proved that there was collusion with
the government which by the way Elon
Musk tweeted and said
um
he said that there that Twitter acted
under orders from the government to
suppress free speech with no judicial
review however mataibi said there's no
evidence to support the fact that the
government was involved because there
wasn't any and in addition again Joe
Biden was not the president in 2020. he
was not even elected they did not even
have the election so he could not be the
government
in October of 2020 when the story was
was put out there and then they said oh
this is misinformation we should handle
it so again there's a lot of lies and
and they're literally exposing them in
real time to say
there was no government involvement Elon
saying there was government involvement
and then him saying oh I gave him
unfettered access he could have it he
could just un you know unrestricted
access just post whatever Matt haibi
says oh no actually there were certain
conditions and restrictions that I had
to agree with then you got Elon Musk
said there's a part two coming no one no
mention from Matt taibi that a part two
is coming he he has not tweeted anything
in the last three days Elon Musk said
it's coming oh we need another day or so
just like he was like oh it's gonna
happen in 40 minutes we just had to
double check some facts it's a [ __ ]
nothing burger with nothing there
there's no Hunter Biden laptop it
doesn't it's not a thing now uh
Shapiro's uh ghost here he always is
posting from uh true social which I like
to grab screenshots over there too but
he's he's he's uh done an exceptional
job at posting the derangement of uh
Trump and let me tell you something this
this is the reason why they did this
Twitter files things is to collude with
trump it this is why they've done it is
they colluding with Trump they're
colluding with this idea
Elon Musk is desperately trying to get
Trump back on Twitter so I believe he
did this I I think that's this whole
reason for it and and it's again it's
the reason why I bought Twitter it's
this stupid cycle that he ends up
because he's red-filled yeah but uh
Shapiro says oh my god get a straight
jacket for this lunatic this was posted
I think it looks about about an hour ago
right am I right on that I think I'll I
will double check right now so Donald
Trump
um from fraud social in all caps we're
in all caps is about an hour ago is that
about yeah simply put is that the one
yeah yeah that one was
56 minutes ago and then he had a more
recent one okay well uh can you pull
that can you give me a screenshot of
that one um yeah well I'll just give you
the link for it is that is is that a CR
is it crazy okay so here is here's the
screenshot of the simply put one
the Cheeto desk uniter says simply now
this is all caps yeah I'm not gonna yell
really bad right simply put if the
election is irrefutable irrefutably
fraudulent it should go to the rightful
winner or at a minimum be redone
we're open and blatant fraud is involved
there should be no time limit for change
again what you're calling for is not in
our constitution there is no going to
rightful winner or being redone what
happens is is there's another election
in four years that's that's just what
happens and you have already filed to
run in that re-election so obviously you
are either you are either trying to
overthrow our government again or you're
running for our government it can't be
both
um obviously we know why he's doing what
he's doing okay now this is the this is
the next how long how long ago was this
one this one was I think like 11 minutes
ago oh so this is uh this is this was uh
done at 10 0 uh sorry uh 10 51 my time
so it was 13 minutes ago
okay so here is um and I'm assuming I'm
assuming this is in response to finding
out that Kerry Lake legitimately lost
because right because they shared it was
certified because it's Republicans that
certified the election by the way okay
so this is 13 minutes ago um grandpa
Poopypants
um again all [ __ ] capitals he's got
the camps lock on today [ __ ]
um it says we want people who quote
legitimately won
the election to lead our country not
people who had to cheat in order to win
exclamation point Exclamation point
Exclamation point I'd be dare licking my
duty if I didn't point out those
exclamation points there are three or
were there four uh the three as far as
okay yeah
three exclamation points
he seems like a guy who would totally uh
oh my god do four instead of three
oh man okay sorry yeah I have another
post here that I I want you to read okay
quickly before because this is what the
topic of today is on yeah this is this
is Trump trying to say that what we
talked about him saying was fake news
which is based on what he truths about
so this is the um
how is this different how is this
different than any other one that he's
posed in the last few days I mean really
this was before the the simply put one
this was an hour so this is an hour ago
this is when it really just like went
off the rails right he didn't have the
Caps locked yeah permanently yeah
um he says the fake news is actually
trying to convince the American people
that I said I want to terminate the
Constitution that's exactly what he said
this is simply more disinformation in
lines just go down your thread dummy
um he says just like Russia Russia
Russia and all their other hoax and
scams what I said was he's gonna tell us
what he said here I'm sure it's going to
be profound what I said was when there
is quote massive
and widespread fraud and deception as
has been irrefutable proof in the 2020
presidential election steps must
immediately
taken to right the wrong Only Fools
would disagree with that and accept
stolen elections Maga okay so he's
saying he's saying I
guess this is a lie I didn't actually
say terminate what I said was there was
massive and widespread fraud and
deception Ergo as a result we should
terminate the Constitution and all the
rights and everything that's good what
the [ __ ] this guy is absolutely insane
it couldn't get more crazy well here's
here's the thing and you know we're
laughing at it because really honestly
this is a caged animal
um this this guy this I mean he's backed
into a corner man well Jack Smith is
going to absolutely uh nail this guy to
a wall it's it's it's a parent now and
he's freaking out the only the reason
why he wants to be president so bad is
because he knows that's the only
protection because his legal team has
probably told him that's the only
protection that he has is to be a
sitting president you don't get the you
don't get the immunity that you get
while you're president when you're not
present it's not a thing there is
nothing anywhere that says that and they
have convinced him that he is [ __ ]
here that he is going to be indicted now
I believe that he did this presidential
campaign to try to prolong a trial
because he knows where the trial is
headed it's headed to him being in
federal prison but I would not be
surprised honestly I would not be
surprised if he's indicted um before the
end of the year I really thought it was
going to be January between March I I
think with the election happening um
this runoff happening and that that
being over I think Jack Smith is going
to strike he's going to strike hard
um and it's not just going to be on the
documents Casey because I believe the
documents cases you know
um is not just about the documents that
he stole it's about January 6 and the
state election team he's hiding [ __ ]
um he's hiding evidence and I think they
undercovered that they uh they found
that evidence at Mar-A-Lago that he was
hiding that he stole
folks I wish we had another four hours
to talk about Hunter Biden's dick and
how it has to do with terminating the
Constitution but this is we're in such a
[ __ ] weird timeline that Hunter
Biden's [ __ ] pictures have to do with
terminating the Constitution literally
that is a story from the weekend and
there's so many things we missed there's
so many things we miss like
um the the proud boys showing up and
dancing to the YMCA to protest an lgbtq
event
um more Nazis literal Nazis and and
um cosplay Nazis like Patriot front show
up and they're fighting about Who's Who
Wants to be more of a Nazi than the
other person
um and then and then you have a North
Carolina where they're they're
sabotaging power grids to shut down
power so they don't have power for
events
um there's a story about the the police
department in Columbus Ohio not giving
proper protection for the people who
asked for it after Club Q only making me
think that possible law enforcement in
Columbus Ohio is colluding with the
proud boys and other organizations
because they want that intimidation
tactic to go forth they want the
intimidation
um and to to [ __ ] strip away people's
rights to assemble and have a [ __ ]
story time thing it really is ridiculous
it's this all comes from the Liberty
Freedom Bros and it's the same [ __ ]
that all weekend jerked off to Hunter
Biden's dick pics it's the same
[ __ ] it's the same
[ __ ] it's weird [ __ ] it's a
weird time in our country's history what
a time to be alive Gabe Sanchez I mean
this what a time something else we are
every every day gets a little bit
weirder and for people in Georgia
for people in Georgia I hope understand
that this is why this is important this
this is so important so tomorrow if you
haven't voted you know voting today vote
tomorrow please go out and support
Senator Raphael Warnock uh candidate the
same candidate is I mean look even
Herschel Walker said Senator Rafael
Warnock he's a good guy so take his word
if you're gonna if you're gonna believe
anything that that that Walker has said
believe him when he says Senator Rafael
Warnock is a great guy or a good guy
everybody will be back tomorrow and I'm
sure we'll have more conversations about
Hunter Biden's [ __ ] and how big it is
and how much a manga is obsessed with it
and I'm sure tomorrow Grandpa Poopypants
will be trying to subvert our
constitution even more in this little
fraud social tweets he's going to be
wanting to be crowned dictator and King
until that time in that place
you know where to find us
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon